[Music]
the life of a North American garden
shrew is run around like crazy for about
a year and then fall over dead like this
poor fella
this shrew is no more it rests in peace
or does it is this a death rattle or is
the shrew actually you know coming back
to life nope this is still an ex shrew
the burying beetles have come they
cackle over their latest fine
this shrew will be food and well
something out of the second Alien movie
that you'll see
before competing scavengers can join
this deadly feast other beetles maggots
raccoons etc the burying beetles have to
move the cadaver to a more favorable
location in order to secure their prize
the beetles conduct their own funeral
procession they lie on their backs and
walk the shrew forward
now for ill grouse moment number one the
burying beetles the pallbearers driven
into a frenzy by this stench of dead
shrew and really who isn't take time out
- how can I say this discretely dance
the horizontal mambo this is the real
Beatle mania I guess the roach motel was
booked up
as the procession moves on even a gate
won't stop these grim reapers from
hauling their cargo
like a landlocked funeral barge the dead
shrew approaches its final resting place
in the burying beetle burrow
[Music]
and nearby in a separate incident we
present you a gross moment number two
this time-lapse shows how maggots can
turn a dead mouse into a tasty meal and
a throw rug we realize this footage has
nothing to do with burying beetles but
it's way cool like the maggots we
couldn't help ourselves back to the
burying beetles it's almost time for the
last gross moment the beetles prepare
their home part coroner slab part
morticians parlor for a daunting home
improvement project to turn this carcass
into a nursery the body is given a shake
and then Oh gross
the beetles embalmed the Shrew with a
protein-rich secretion that comes from
their mouths and anuses
now the shrews ready for that thing we
mentioned earlier from that alien movie
the female will lay her eggs near the
decomposing shrew which the mom beetle
will chew and regurgitate for them the
rotting carcass is baby food and baby
nursery come on is that any worse than
mating on a dead body
[Music]